[Music]
in dangers of streaming news submitted
by Maura fan from Sudan Oh gaming
streamers are concerned for the safety
after a shooting at doctor disrespects
house Oh Gina was talking about whose
doctor disrespect he is a very popular
twitch streamer and I actually worked
with someone that has like like in video
like we did a scene together that that
recently did something with him right
and this guy he's a buff old man he's a
pretty big guy he's like 511 or so he's
old no no no the guy that I worked with
and so he took a photo with doctor
disrespect and this guy's like 610 or
some [ __ ] like wow he's massive like
they took a picture and it looked like
me and Steve yeah 610 no I'm just making
that up but it's like it's it's like
past six five or something he's tall I
didn't know that because he's always
sitting down but he he has this
character that's called doctors
disrespect he wears a wig you've
probably seen him before like we
probably did a JK news but like he wears
like glasses and yeah yeah I was trying
to remember cuz he looked familiar to me
I'm like I think we talked about 4jk me
I can't remember but now we're talking
about him again and so recently while he
was streaming there was some sounds
going on so he left the stream he went
to go check it out and then this is when
he came back
ladies gentlemen I got a [ __ ] in uh
I've got it in the broadcast right now
at our house broken [ __ ] upstairs
window this is the second shot someone
shot yesterday I had a so much shot
yesterday at our [ __ ] house and
someone shot again right now I'm
connected with the house upstairs right
you're driving by right you've that's
crazy man trying to buy shootings ladies
he dead
give me the broke character so what
happened was and I wanted you guys to
see his character - that would have been
cool if he did it in character yeah
cause it's my first impression of him
and now that's all he is no no that's
not who he really is so what happened
was that someone shot up his house in
the upstairs bedroom luckily no one was
there
later on the cops determined that that
was a BB gun but this is the second time
during that week that his house has been
shot at so then this the second time is
also be be good I'm not sure about the
hard time but the second time was a big
oh I see yeah
so then this is his first stream after
that and you're just addressing it so or
addressing that he's um that's his
character
this is his character here though oh
wait yeah let's get it out of the way am
I gonna be talking about anything
related to what happened yesterday today
no not making a big deal about it I love
how he's a cactus blade being handled so
then that this is when it happened
against all I'm gonna say about it this
is his first stream after the second
shot so the first shot middle one knew
that was the first shot until he
mentioned it this is the second time
yeah I love how he's explaining it a
character that's so dope wish but people
shouldn't be correlating the two a like
oh if I stream I might get my house shot
at well there are they are because
recently there was this what is it like
a tournament thing that happened and two
people died whoa why those are shooting
because the some guy brought a gun in
and he was one of the tournament people
and then he just blew a couple other
people away with because he lost his
along and killed himself so the only
people that died including the what the
[ __ ] is wrong with people well I mean if
they could figure out where you live
they stop when you're streaming because
you know they've been doing slotting for
like a while now or I like I think is
this loitering thing a kid died or as a
person died because of the swatting yeah
whole thing so you know what swatting is
when they send the SWAT team to yes yeah
so then there's like all these things
are happening in the gaming the
streaming community and so everyone's
just like really scared they're really a
lot of these streamers are saying that
they will not be attending twitchcon and
that they're just like really because
they want to have guaranteed safety
right it's [ __ ] Skinner they're upset
because they don't feel like the
conventions take it seriously safety
exactly but there are metal detectors
there a lot of it I think like no matter
what though as things grow and get more
popular the more people it attracts
right it's a population thing cuz like
if you think about football right like
how many like things happen like during
a game where people get stabbed or like
after the game were like people get hurt
and they fight or even in bars yeah like
if people get shot because like yeah
different teams and they're wearing this
Jersey or whatever like I think it
happens whenever it attracts more and
more people so with what to me I say
this think this seems kind of like
fear-mongering because if you don't have
stats of like how many people are really
getting shot from streaming in their
house I don't know you know it just is
just let's click and then get be afraid
what's crazy too is you know people who
love to sees all these [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] for political issues so at the
convention shooting a bunch of people
who are like Oh
violence in video games will cause this
that's what I was gonna say games is
what caused this they were playing
[ __ ] Madden dude they're playing
Madden like you they weren't playing a
violent video game [ __ ] they'll just be
like the emojis and all the video game
guns will be water guns yeah dude it's
but it is you
saying where it's like they don't even
they read the headline they extrapolate
and then project their stupid pool my
nephews little friend said it the best
because his mom was telling him the same
thing because she's like why are you
you're playing all these violent games
like you're just gonna start turning
violet and he goes well mom you watch a
lot of cooking like videos and stuff and
your cooking sauce that's like my horror
mom watching HGTV and her it doesn't
make sense doesn't make any sense
but exactly yeah I mean there are
studies that that show like if you if
you get it out of your system
it's it's actually better like cathartic
yeah yeah like then you wouldn't do it
in real life you're getting all the
aggression out in the video game it's
like therapy does it release the whole
thing behind purge movies - and they're
like one day you can kill whoever you
want and the rest of the year we yeah
yeah yeah so then twitchcon was saying
so this takes place in October in San
Jose they're saying that they are adding
additional security measure measures on
top of past event measures because they
want people to feel like they're fully
100% safe going but they're still
streamer saying like I'm not going just
because of this one event or just
everything about compiling a lot a lot
of the sports games and concerts and
like when you go to Disneyland they do
have metal detectors and now you're
saying that you can well I don't know it
actually passed but I was reading that
there are these plans that you can print
your own gun from plastic well you have
to have a feed 3d printer and those
things are expensive and you still need
bullets - well you still need bullets
really you guys I don't know about that
like plastic no no you you they use
regular bullets yeah yeah like that the
the 3d printed a ours they still shoot
regular bolt yeah yeah
note the plastic it's a carbon or
sumption right I forgot they print on
you they did on Vice I watch them use a
3d printed gun it doesn't have like a
long you like life like you can't it
gets [ __ ] up after
I don't know like a like a short amount
of time but you can't shoot 10,000
rounds out of it like resin or what is
the material I don't know what that
Paterno material actually is it's
dangerous you know after this the
biggest thing a lot of people were
scared to go to musical concerts you're
not letting people afraid to fly it's
just it's yeah it's like this this this
hysteria svet has to pass and then it'll
be fine again but but then the question
because just becomes how much of this is
cultural how much of this is just a
singular event that people are talking
about and creating fear from I'm kind of
desensitized though like I read and
watch so much news all over the world
and if it's not humans that I'm afraid
of then it's natural disasters or
accidents or whatever or like a cut and
then you get bacteria and you [ __ ]
guys oh yeah there's so many things that
you can and wary and be afraid of but he
definitely universe or even like I was
reading about all these like deaths
during giving birth to kids and yeah
[ __ ] how am I ever gonna get have a kid
like it's so scary you got to start the
vagina stretching process early on yeah
and I think we could try it out tonight
the most liberating thing for me was was
accepting death with what how dare you
everything big honey yeah I got you this
big I heard I got big elbows dude don't
even worry about it
I'll get him nervous a lot in there dude
yeah that's a lot of fun yeah that's a
lot like that's like Joe saying that he
used to [ __ ] just his elbows and [ __ ]
yeah I tried this I tried this I tried
this I tried everything I tried every
crevice dick slime everywhere maybe no
why didn't you think of closing the year
that's good a new trial things are you
guys giggling and laughing are you like
in the horny face oh yeah no I mean like
we're laughing hard it's just
experimenting man like how do you stay
hard yeah she has her ways when you're
but the entire Oh stay hard either
even if she's doing a full stand-up set
maybe in ten years what maybe in ten
years I'll accept that but right now
it's too difficult
you ever have sex in a public bathroom
in a public bathroom I don't remember
you said you had sex somewhere uh well
was it chick-fil-a yeah no no no we okay
so we were vlogging that after we like
to eat chick-fil-a and after chick-fil-a
we like to [ __ ] and then her dad bought
us
chick-fil-a gift cards you basically
bought you [ __ ] gift cards which is
awesome it's a good gift from dad eat it
into the family
yeah that's acceptance that's true
acceptance yes that's her dad's way of
saying I'm watching something careful oh
that's what I sound like an endorsement
yeah because if you buy you like $100
worth of chick-fil-a gift cards that
means you have to go another like ten
more time
you're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] after
chick-fil-a and then he got you the
cards and it's like oh okay then that
makes sense yes he gave you a dollar on
chick-fil-a that's a sign true or if
he's like he if he got you gifts gift
cards to Chili's then he knows that he
doesn't approve don't go there
yeah he's like you goods go to Chili's
okay they're gonna have so much gas you
don't wanna [ __ ] exactly
[Music]